let's see how the inflation surge is
affecting americans like you all across
the country
senior national correspondent rich edson
is here in the washington area at a
grocery store tonight good evening rich
good evening brad and throughout the
washington d.c area this week we had
plenty of reports and are seeing some
pretty empty grocery store shelves
entire sections of salad meat eggs for
example were bare pretty tough if you're
on a keto diet grocery store workers in
the area we spoke with say last week's
weather in the northeast delayed
shipments that's on top of worker
shortages and the omicron covet 19 surge
honestly it looks like
march of 2020 when everybody was
stockpiling and the shelves were fair
it's like a soviet
store during uh 1981. horrible
everything meat egg uh dairy certain
breads were out most vegetables
it was all fresh items
many of the d.c area stores that were
empty monday and tuesday are largely
stocked this evening though shoppers are
reporting shortages at stores across the
country fmi is a trade group
representing grocery stores and food
suppliers they told us the food supply
is healthy though quote a combination of
several factors from labor and
transportation shortages to recent
extreme weather events continues to
impact the movement of food through the
supply chain these issues can be
difficult for grocery stores to predict
as they're often regional we have the
loudest ambulances in the nation i kid
you not on that front but also back to
this story brett there are other trade
associations saying that they've got
other issues that they have to confront
we heard reports from companies talking
about they've had more positive tests in
the past two weeks than they had in all
of 2020.
those positive tax tests are taking
people off the front lines it's forcing
companies to shut down manufacturing
lines preemptively and it's leading to
just simply not enough supplies
now the consumer brands association says
grocery stores typically have a five to
ten percent of their items out of stock
at any given time right now that
unavailable unavailability number
according to that group is around 15
percent especially when it comes to food
there's a surplus of sirens uh rich
edson here in dc rich thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else